en el vídeo pasado hablé de la propuesta
de rescate del gobierno
básicamente quién tomar 700 billones de
pesos y comprar unos de estos activos
apestosos estos cedros que tienen un
montón de bancos en sus hojas de balance
y que han provocado que muchos de estos
bancos caigan en picada o al menos que
muchos de estos bancos dejen de
prestarle dinero a otros bancos
provocando la cascada de la que hablamos
en el vídeo pasado existe la posibilidad
de que eso resuelva el problema pero
incluso si lo hace es horrible porque si
compras estos activos
digamos que valen cero y pagas dos
billones por ellos esencialmente le
estás dando un cheque a los dueños de
las acciones ellos se han beneficiado
los últimos cinco años recibiendo
dividendos y rendimientos y otras cosas
y ahora cuando las cosas salen mal no
sufren por las consecuencias del riesgo
que tomaron los que pagan los impuestos
son los que terminan sufriendo las
consecuencias entonces estás dándoles un
cheque de un millón de pesos a los
accionistas y un cheque de un millón de
pesos a los dueños de los préstamos de
la compañía
hayas oído la frase riesgo moral este es
un caso donde hay riesgo moral oye le
estás escribiendo un cheque justo a las
personas que tomaron malas decisiones
los dueños de las acciones tomaron malas
decisiones las personas que le prestaron
dinero a esa compañía tomaron malas
decisiones para empezar las personas que
invirtieron en esta compañía no se
dieron cuenta del riesgo y además
muchísimos de los dueños de las acciones
son los que manejan la compañía los que
la administran y son justo ellos los que
invirtieron en estos dedos apestosos y
si compras estos vídeos no estás
castigando los por tomar malas
decisiones se quedan con todos sus bonos
tal vez incluso se queden con sus
trabajos y estás aumentando el precio de
sus acciones regalándoles dinero ese es
un elemento de riesgo moral que corremos
el otro lado que tiene muchos matices y
es el más importante es que si el
gobierno llega a salvar la situación
cada vez que hay algún tipo de estrés
financiero entonces en un futuro cercano
las personas van a decir hey yo voy a
tomar todos los riesgos del mundo porque
cuando los tiempos son
voy a hacer mucho dinero y con los
tiempos sean malos hemos visto ya muchas
veces que el gobierno está más que listo
para llegar y rescatar el sector privado
todas estas personas tomaron riesgos
obtuvieron su recompensa por ello pero
cuando el riesgo los tratan mal el
gobierno llega y los rescata y no tienen
que lidiar con las consecuencias y al
final de cuentas está el riesgo moral de
que ahora sea más probable que ocurran
todas estas burbujas en un futuro porque
las personas se van a preocupar menos
por el riesgo van a decir mira esos
idiotas tomaron todos los riesgos del
mundo compraron cd2 otras personas les
prestaron dinero a esas personas que
compran los vídeos están completamente a
plantados y el gobierno los rescató así
es que puedo tomarme riesgos enormes
obtendré una recompensa grandísima por
ello y en el futuro cuando lo necesite
el gobierno va a venir a rescatarme ese
es el otro elemento de riesgo moral en
fin yo diría que hay un riesgo moral muy
fuerte con la propuesta actual de
rescate financiero del gobierno tal vez
el riesgo moral vale la pena si previene
que suceda toda esta cascada de eventos
si de alguna forma hace que las personas
se prestan dinero entre sí sobre todo
que le presten dinero al mundo real al
señor que quiere construir una fábrica o
al granjero que quiere comprar las
semillas para la cosecha del año que
entra lo que he escuchado y no conozco
exactamente los números y no soy ninguna
experta en el asunto dicen que hay
alrededor de 50 billones de estos cebos
tóxicos repartidos en las hojas de
balance de muchas instituciones
financieras no sé si es acertado el
número lo que existe es que 7 billones
es relativamente una fracción pequeña
del total en las hojas de balance y
bernanke y paulson lo que dice es
nosotros sabemos que 7 billones no les
llega ni a los talones al precio de
todos ellos que hay incluso si los
compramos al precio de remate lo que
esperamos hacer al ir con esta enorme
cantidad de dinero y empezar a comprarse
dedos esperaríamos así crear una especie
de mercado para estos dedos y están
hablando de hacer una subasta inversa
donde dirás ok
estamos dispuestos a comprar uno
así es que de los bancos si quieren
vendernos lo equivalente a un billón en
cd o se les compraremos al que nos dé el
mejor precio
esta es una subasta inversa vas y dices
quiero comprar quién me va a vender tal
cosa al mejor precio al precio más
barato ellos esperan que así se originen
intereses privados y digan oigan el
gobierno está obteniendo un excelente
trato con estos deseos yo también quiero
comprar y entonces tal vez otras
personas empiecen a comprar estos vídeos
la razón por la que yo digo que no va a
funcionar es porque si otras personas
fueran a comprar estos vídeos ya lo
habrían hecho el problema es que cuando
hagan la subasta inversa y digan tengo
un billón de pesos que quiero gastar en
sede os paulson y bernanke dicen que eso
creará una especie de precio de mercado
para estos deseos y que estos bancos
podrán marcar sus activos y todo el
mundo sabrá cuánto valen dos problemas
para empezar ese no es un precio de
mercado porque el gobierno está creando
demanda artificial si el gobierno no
estuviera tratando de rescatar la
situación
habría ninguna entidad con un millón de
pesos queriendo comprar esos activos y
se valorarían por menos dinero el
segundo problema es que si el gobierno
hace la subasta inversa y las personas
se dan cuenta de que estos dos billones
de ese dios incluso cuando el gobierno
hace la subasta inversa en realidad sólo
valen medio billón y muy probablemente
las personas que los venderían son las
más solventes porque a ellos no los
haría caer en la bancarrota si en
realidad valen medio billón entonces
todos los bancos que tienen los mismos
sede os tendrían que corregir sus hojas
de balance y rebajar el valor de 2
billones a medio billón y por lo tanto
desaparece su capital y la cascada
empieza de nuevo entonces no creo que
funcione en sus propuestas número 1 no
creo que vayan a crear un precio de
mercado real en el que alguien vaya a
confiar
y no creo que vayan a hacer que nadie
más quiera comprarlos honestamente si
alguien creyera que estos son buenos
negocios hay un montón de inversores muy
sofisticados que tienen mucho más
conocimiento acerca de cuánto valen
estos activos que la tesorería del
gobierno y si creyeran que son buenos
tratos te aseguro que ya los habrían
comprado hay capital allá afuera y los
inversores irían y comprarían esos
activos por lo que ellos consideran que
es un buen trato un buen negocio y los
mantendrían hasta su madurez hay mucho
efectivo y yo creo que eso es algo
importante que se le olvida a la gente
hay un montón de personas que tienen un
montón de efectivo y no quieren
invertirlo en los vídeos porque son un
mal negocio y las personas están
buscando un buen negocio y que otra
solución podemos encontrar muchas
personas han estado hablando mucho
acerca de otra solución
ellos dicen bueno y por qué no llega el
gobierno y en lugar de comprar estos
deseos lo cual es esencialmente
escribirles un cheque justo a las
personas a las que nos metieron en esta
ciudad
porque no mejor compran acciones de esta
compañía ya hemos hablado de estas
situaciones en nuestro ejemplo en uno de
los vídeos pasados llegó un fondo
soberano y le pagó 3 billones en
efectivo a una compañía a cambio de
acciones y así la compañía pudo pagar
sus deudas esa no es tan mala idea pero
yo no diría que es una buena idea está
diluyendo las acciones pero qué pasa si
este capital vale cero qué pasa si estos
dos billones de cde os valen cero
entonces la compañía es insolvente tiene
tres billones de activos 4 billones de
pasivos esto en realidad es un capital
de menos un billón de pesos entonces las
acciones no tienen ningún valor el
precio correcto de las acciones la
correcta capitalización de mercado es de
menos un billón para que pagarías un
precio mayor que cero por esas acciones
entonces incluso en esta situación si
esto realmente vale cero y el gobierno
compra un montón de estas acciones
haciendo una infusión de efectivo
salvando a la compra
y penalizando ligeramente a los
accionistas de la compañía porque de
repente en lugar de que sus 500 mil
millones de acciones conformarán el 100
por ciento de la compañía ahora el
gobierno tiene tal vez 2 millones de
acciones y entonces los 500 mil millones
de acciones pasan a ser únicamente el 20
por ciento de la compañía y bueno eso es
exactamente lo que pasó con aeg tal vez
digas que esa es una buena situación
pero aún así es un pequeño golpe al
gobierno y francamente si el gobierno
hiciera eso yo creo que el riesgo con
respecto a la recompensa es razonable
digamos que hay medio millón de acciones
ahorita y el gobierno dice le vamos a
dar esta compañía 4 billones en efectivo
y por ello queremos 4 billones de
acciones o mejor hagámoslo muy intenso
digamos que quieren 10 millones de
acciones
entonces esencialmente están pagando 40
centavos por acción
van a tener 10 millones de acciones aquí
o sea un total de 10 puntos 5 millones
de acciones
no me parece una situación tan mala
entonces la compañía ahora tendrá 4
billones en efectivo y tres billones en
otros activos y estos se de osh que muy
probablemente valen cero y ahora sí sin
importar lo que pase esta compañía no
puede caer en la bancarrota tiene 4
billones de efectivo y cuatro billones
de pasivos podría pagar sus pasivos con
la infusión del capital y las personas
que merecen sufrir las consecuencias de
los riesgos que tomaron las sufren no el
100% porque los rescató el gobierno pero
sufren suficiente porque ahora son
dueños de menos del 5 por ciento de su
compañía en lugar del 100% sin embargo
eso es mejor que ser dueño de un capital
de menos un billón de una compañía que
ya quebró y no valen nada así es que
esta puede ser una situación justa
aunque en esta situación sigue
rescatando íntegramente a las personas
que le prestan dinero a este banco ellos
le prestan dinero a una institución a la
que no le debieron haber prestado dinero
ellos deberían haber investigado mucho
mejor
qué activos tóxicos tenían estas
compañías a las que le prestaron dinero
ellos recibieron muchos intereses de
esta institución y justo cuando esta
institución va a quebrar el gobierno
hasta esta enorme infusión de capital y
básicamente compra la compañía la hace
una parte del gobierno porque ahora el
gobierno es dueño del noventa y tantos
por ciento de la compañía y le va a
pagar a los dueños de estos bonos así es
que yo diría que todavía hay un poco de
riesgo moral porque en el futuro todos
seguirán prestándole dinero a otros
bancos insolventes con activos tóxicos
porque dirán cuando las cosas se pongan
mal el gobierno va a llegar y rescatar
los bancos comprando un montón de
acciones así es que no van a evaluar
adecuadamente el riesgo ni ponerle un
precio adecuado pero si eso hace que se
abra el mercado y las personas empiecen
a prestarle dinero al granjero o al que
quería construir una fábrica
tal vez vale la pena bueno a mí parecer
si el gobierno está preocupado por estos
bancos
está preocupado por este pedazo por el
granjero que necesita un préstamo o la
persona que quiere construir una fábrica
y necesita un préstamo porque no toma
esos 7 billones y crean un fondo para
prestarle directamente al mundo real a
la economía real porque no dejan que
todos estos bancos quiebren van a
terminar regresando y volverán más
limpios más eficientes con medidas de
riesgo adecuadas y todo el mundo será
castigado apropiadamente y así en el
siguiente ciclo no habrá todo este
riesgo moral y tiene 7 billones que se
van a ir directamente a los granjeros y
a compañías que están construyendo cosas
creando capital y muchas cosas que
realmente son necesarias si seguro el
proceso de a quién le prestas dinero se
va a poner muy politizado y tal vez
tengas que hacer
subastas inversas u otras cosas y seguir
habiendo algo de riesgo moral el punto
es que si el gobierno estuviera
realmente interesado en la economía real
en el granjero y lo demás ellos no
usarían estos 7 billones de pesos en
esta forma tan indirecta
le prestarían dinero directamente a la
economía real al granjero y al
constructor y a todos los demás bueno te
veo en el próximo vídeo